i think there's a massive war on  masculinity right now to really show  this war and masculinity across media  outlets they're talking about you know  if a man wants to work out and he's got  muscles it means he's right-wing and  he's probably going to be sexist and a  misogynist i mean what the hell is that  the government this system they want you  weak they want men particular to be weak  fat and compliant so that they can't  fight the tyranny because when you're  weak fat and compliant addicted to porn  and unable to get outside your house and  actually be aware of what's going on in  the world then the powers that be have  more control when men are strong when  men are intelligent when men are  entrepreneurs when men are hitting the  gym that is not good for those who are  in charge